hello good afternoon everyone so for all
of you who don't know drums keep
speaking to me ROM thank you for coming
lock the doors
so I'm trying go through this so two
things one there's a lot of power
pointing stuff but we will see code so
don't freak out and two I'm going to try
get through this stuff quite quickly so
you can fire any questions or we can go
to any examples and what this is going
to be we're gonna kind of go into XML
and meld on there but more importantly
so who here is done
who's just a who's just about who's a
developer who's done machine learning
who's done ml dot map awesome okay so
basically I want to go through how we as
a company and as an individual we went
as developers and we went through this
journey of how to add AI into what has
now become a soon-to-be expertise or
proficient with an ml donor but before
we start
because all good talks start with a rap
video Ben David and yo 4:30 again I'm
stumbling around trying to make it to
the fridge and check my calendar on my
fitting down but is the flu flash green
or brown I know is that the wrong filled
to the brim and if I bring the wrong
London thing so here grandma can't mix
things up if I work too hard to separate
that I can hear the truck coming ain't
no cop and the Tate regular a recycle
always seem to alternating thought but
only really comes whenever it's a summer
day maybe Southside point and laugh and
making fun of me ever since
Oh next week they're gonna be
embarrassed oh yeah you betcha cuz next
time I'm just gonna ask Alexa No
[Music]
you will now not be able to get this out
of your head which is the point so that
was the kind of turning point for us is
we had been doing Alexis stuff and we
wanted to create something amazing and
what's more amazing than a Fisher what
your recycling bin out so under it chop
around quite a bit but in the view of
giving you some amazing value so who was
seen github search experiments no so
this is probably going to scare you all
because it will eventually put you out
of a job at home all inspire you so
github up an experiment called somatic
search which is so new if you're working
on load code loads large code base and
you're trying to find that bit of code
that swarms wrote that let's say is
around creating of them a plot chart or
let's say is the IP address so basically
you can be used natural language and it
will find the code in that four language
you can even say the search yourself so
drawing a line and if you can't find the
thing then it'll just give you some
suggestions so where's the code that
scrapes the data from the website and
this is an experiment get up you can see
the code now and it's very simple but
it's got a great use case the same way
that PowerPoint has this great feature
now called design ideas has anyone seen
this it is amazing so I can just write
on here a sentence such as I would like
to go to the beach I'm write an article
about how awesome nd seals now I can
design this I can style it up or I can
just use these different design ideas
these are all quite basic and quite
simple but let's say for example I say
on here Beach writing obviously love
work what you'll find is it will then
just start basically analyzing the words
I'm using little grab thumbnails grab
icons and create this amazing experience
all in PowerPoint which is basically
just a way to show you that the AI that
we're using now is very much here today
it's not a future thing anymore
and for us we got really involved in
this technology around voice and
particularly following a guy called
Brian it is not a crazy inventor guy
that you hear what you see on the TV and
stuff like this is the dude and the
reason why he's so tall is because this
will leave a freak you out or amazing if
you have to really listen okay oh so who
whose English is their second language
so this might just sound like a normal
sentence to you all right so just sounds
like weird sounds okay right this one he
was sitting at his desk in his office
right get ready to have your mind blown
see this is the first one again so Brian
has been working on this technology to
do this but also what's be even crazier
he's able to put into touch so you can
just come here touch and it'll basically
save that sentence to in your head
amazing
so so my name's Lee Mullin I work at a
consultancy Corellian possible and we
work with enterprise to do innovation
stuff cool things and over the years
we've worked on websites we've worked on
mobile applications we worked in voice
we tried to fly drones through
supermarket so they stopped checking I
do not advise it drones do not work
inside very well you will cut your hand
open and then we started to become a bit
more intelligent not the stuff we were
making so we've got analyze and user
behavior with a be test and then a I
came along and we started using things
like cognitive services because who
doesn't need another example detecting
how people smile on a on a website and
then they start again with a kid and
then an old object came along as a
precursor though I just want to make
sure you all understand if we do Q&A I
am NOT a data scientist if you start
asking me about loss functions or
r-squared ratios I will look confused at
you this is very much a as a developer
how can you embrace how how can you use
this technology to better what you're
doing and it rarely our main mission is
to use technology to provide convenience
for our clients so what's the minimum
amount of steps that they can take to
either use your product by your product
or delight to the experience and when ml
dotnet came along we've been a xamarin
partner before so cross-platform mobile
applications ml don't seem to be the way
for us to have the same experience
within the machine learning situation
but what we found was the coding as I'll
show you that ml dotnet is pretty simple
the examples I'll show you are like 50
60 lines of code it's not complicated
the bit is complicated and painful and
all driving the scene is the testing the
configuration and the iteration over
Linux so what that did was talk us from
a code first approach to a problem first
approach because we could no longer
tweak how rounded a corner was on
something or was this page on a mobile
app responsive or had pinch we really
had to kind of say look we need to get
this data to be able to do these things
and how this also for us as a company
and just as people is we started using
tools that started adding AI
functionality so whose use smart replies
from Gmail so smart replies user to send
in an email and what will happen is it
will just Auto suggest the things that
you would likely reply with and it gets
really really good it's even polite er
than how you would typically respond
back and then we started using tools
like grammerly that don't if anyone's
use grammerly so grammerly is a plug-in
you can use and you as your write blogs
it will just correct your very about
English but what's a great way this is
we used to pay copywriters to just proof
read our blogs or content we've
completely eradicated that now and
grammerly does it all for us and once
we've been using these tools we start
thinking like how can we integrate AI
within the things we were building so
company approached us and they were they
had a customer service department so to
get emails in and they were getting low
NPS scores and Net Promoter Score and
well that is all you likely to refer
this to a friend and what we found was
by scanning with their consent their
outbound emails we just checked the
sentiment of the emails they were
sending out and then we concatenate them
into the morning and afternoon Monday to
Friday with a positive or negative
sentiment surprisingly is a lot more
negative Friday morning after the beers
it seems and we send this report back to
the person who'd been send them out so
the management would never see it but
the the member of staff was HELOC and on
Wednesday morning your sentiment seems
to be a bit low
Monday afternoon it seems to be high and
within two weeks sentiment went up by
20% across the board because people were
able to see the data and see how their
mood was influencing how they behaved
and we kind of thought could we turn
this into something that everyone could
do you know when you get an email from
someone and you think you're right in
your pie and you do kind of thing should
I send this and so we created a home for
game which you can download now called
should I send it which we should show
you
so it's very simple
so if I was just saying here hi how are
you today and I can just highlight the
text and it just puts this nice little
smiley face in the corner and if I press
that and the demo gods are on my favour
and wife is yep perfect so then it'll
give me a green place which shows for
the sentiments over kind of sixty-five
percent but let's say I'm feeling a bit
grumpy and I'm like you are being a
complete ass which obviously is not
something you would ever write if it's
green with it's gonna be quite
embarrassing and then it gives you a red
so it's very simple now the plug-in the
API the integration into Azure is less
than a hundred lines of code on the free
tier up to five hundred relaxing
transactions it doesn't cost anything I
bet so we kind of added this
functionality into things that we've
done and then we're like what else can
we do so we created this thing called
high or low which who's used the emotion
API so dinners your anyone a little bit
you know okay so audience participation
so you can play this yourself with
friends though it can be slightly
embarrassing so we're just going to
choose the celebrity version so what
this does is you load it with pictures
and then it sends off to the emotion EP
guys on a tour and estimates how all the
person is and then it shows you another
picture and the idea is it tells you is
the person younger or older so let's
have an audience game so is personate
younger or older than present be bear in
mind this is the computer figuring out
not reality Janka older i know it's the
real clock but do you think younger
person is younger than pee
yeah perfect he's older than B so
basically it's a fun game and you know
you play think what's the point of this
but what we did is we took that and then
you could load it up pictures of friends
which is that a fun game but then you
can load it with pictures of children's
rushes and then you can use that game as
a way to train your models and your
learning of this rash is more severe
than this rice or this banana is off
compared to this piranha and basically
you can game a5 the ability to train and
collect machine learning data which is
where this ended up which kind of leads
us on to training a model so we we
started using tools and then we started
to use some api's but then we wanted to
go it's not really doing what we want to
do so we need to train the model next
let me create this tool this thing
called voicebank so I've been working a
lot with the lexer every time I say I
just think some someone's gonna want to
look dim it's gonna start talking to me
and we were working with brands and they
want to use our own voice want to create
the Disney that we saw the night freeze
and then we thought what if everyone
could create their own voice Alexa tell
me a story
sure once upon a time there was a little
girl she lived in a castle with her
cuddly bear every night her granddad
would tell her tales of dragons and
heroes
Rhonda please tell me a story
[Music]
okay puppet once upon a time it was a
drag again and if I had a Wayland
[Music]
so the concept of voicebank was very
much to be so the content of the voice
bank was that we could build an
application we could do some research
research and again let's not think of
developer code because the code for the
mobile app for this took about two days
to build there's 60 64 sounds in the
English language phonemes so we had to
construct sentences which include it's
all dem sounds which is about two
thousand so you can record two thousand
sound sentences and by reading them in
to its mobile application and then in
essence you have got a digital training
data for your voice that you can keep
forever
or you could upload it to as your google
amazon and basically create a
text-to-speech verse from you have our
own voice such chance this one so so
this is a colleague of mine so this is
her real voice so that's Claire's real
voice and this is only with a hundred
sentences so not the normal two thousand
hi my name is Claire and my voice has
been created by voice bank voice bank
enables you to digitize your voice and
use it in many different way so you can
tell the computer eyes but you can also
you can hear the kind of mannerisms of
how she would speak and that's something
with a hundred sentences so if we use a
few thousand that we can get a more
humanistic approach now by what could
you use this for so obviously there's
the obvious ones of brands using it but
let's just say that you recorded your
voice forgot about it and then you lost
a voice that you could create a digital
version of your own voice or if a loved
one passed away so we built this we
built this tall and one of the news
pieces we built it for was dementia care
so people with onset dementia it's quite
early to detect and one of the problems
with dementia is you kind of forget the
things that you'd said so what happens
if you could record all of them still
digitized voice you could then play back
them stories in the person's voice and
just kind of keep their kind of fables
with them I want to be done all these
things we start get to the point now
where okay we can train people's models
we've used them and now we need to start
building their own which we started
building things like a tool called photo
price which in essence is the ability
for if you're a retailer we take all of
the products that are for sale in retail
including our categorization and then
let's say you want to launch a new
product or you want to tweak the product
picture our tool will basically you drop
it in and it will tell you roughly what
that product was sell for based on the
photo and then once we've done that the
next step which is not written we're not
there yet is when you stop researching
your own algorithms where you really
want to take control and but this is
like a data science division or will
cost you a fortune so you really need to
have a specific use case in mind to do
it so very quickly we're just going to
do a kind of machine learning what I
want so there's a great example and I've
created a short URL and rarely dot IO /
mi st and and it as an on day as a
developer and as a non-date scientist
I've watched hundreds of hours of
YouTube videos Coursera courses and
they're all created by data scientists
so they're really heavy on an ass though
quite confusing that link will take you
to a video which is introduction to
neural networks and it's by far the best
one I found
I'm from watching all these things like
any decent framework or technology it's
all about the acronym so people remember
the thing and the process so I give you
purchase at
just rolls off the tongue we should
basically like a 9-step process to to
basically get machine learning working
and the reason why we've kind of talked
about data and acquiring this
information and not really about the
code is because the code is literally
like 10% of the process so the first
thing and the most important thing is
what is the problem what is the thing
you want to solve and I know we have
this in development where you know
business says what the problem is and
then we won't build something and then
we show it to them and they say it's not
right and then we go back on the
forwards like it's really difficult to
do this with models because you need the
data to be able to create it you've got
to answer the data you've got to acquire
it so you really need to get some
amazing metrics as to like what will how
will you judge if this project is
successful and then you've got to get
the data it's all about the data
so we're going to do an example of how
this works right I I do need a volunteer
from the audience who would like to
volunteer if not I will pick someone any
volunteers
yeah perfect
okay can you put your mind coming up
okay now everyone regret this because
you get 20 quid okay so so basically
what I kind of want to portray here is
how so my job now is that money's yours
we're in London you'll be able to get a
pint potentially and my job is through
what it's going to be this persona on
the screen it's try and convince you to
give me this money back okay so my name
is John I'm 33 years old I've got two
kids thinking about it oh I was easy
okay so at that point would you probably
give me the money on the line
okay so what's it about I can't get them
I can't buy any bread tonight yeah okay
you can give the money you can sit down
thanks very much so like it's a beefy
one saying is as you gather more data
you kind of get to understand the
problem obviously you would have give me
the money and then the next one would be
my son's eel as you get more information
but the problem is with the kind of
machine learning is more data is not
necessarily the answer because
eventually you find some information
which skews the results a little bit so
you've got to be really careful the
information you get and it's not always
about the the amount in the volume it is
about the right information so then the
next step is around splitting the data
so if you're not familiar with how a lot
of these algorithms work is let's say
you're able to get hold of a million
records of a data there a million things
that have happened and they've existed
so you kind of need to split it so
because you want to test on real data
not on stuff you've made up or you don't
just apply your model in a field and
hope it works
so 8020 principle is a pretty good start
so you've got a million records
you take 200,000 out keep them to the
side never expose them to the model at
all because the models are clever and
they they will multiply they will try
and kind of infer
test it on 800,000 and then basically
run your model against the 200,000 and
then you'll get some accuracy ratings
and then you can tweet and go from there
and then the next step like all good
transformers is to transform so this is
where you get your information but
you've got to remember that with these
models the models don't they're not like
the models aren't clever this is not
Skynet like it's just maths it's just
really hard maths and all they do is
understand numbers so you can't really
give it text you can't give it you know
anything you can give you an image you
just giving it colors and brightnesses
and things so you need to transform this
information into numbers and then you
need to choose your algorithm so whose
data scientist or kind of just a bit
more heavy ml stuff anyone that wants to
own up okay if you ask a data scientist
which algorithm you should use none of
them will tell you they're just like wow
try a few and see what happens and
that's the problem is no one knows so
basically you can you can research this
and you can kind of isolate it down to
three or four and then it really is
about training in the model and once you
train the model so this can take seconds
as we'll see in some of their demos or
one of those which I was hoping to show
you was training for 15 hours yesterday
and still didn't finish
so once you've been testing and training
he then got a deploy it so you because
you can have a model the accuracy maybe
is 90% but will it work by being nine
percent right but you know if you're if
it's controlling a plane you know ten
percent is a bit concerning so we need
to monitor the usage and make sure it
solves the problem in question so over
to ml so a bit of a cheat sheet so if
you go to the ml repo on github the tag
line is a cross-platform salute open
source solution for machine learning for
developers and literally that is the
sentence before we hit the science and
then they talk about regression and
binary classifications and clustering
and basically what it is regression is
if you want to predict a number so if
you want to predict sales or if you want
to predict the likelihood of a price of
something it's a regression if you want
to say ham or spam then it's a binary
classification if you want to label
something so there's a great github
labeler so you send in the issue and
then say if it's you know is it system
got link is it system dikes and our
example and or clustering you have a
group of people like in the audience
those who want to own up as being a data
scientist those who don't those who are
thinking about it and then you have some
terminologies within a mile map and the
spec so at the moment there's about
twelve videos on YouTube about ml that
they are all out of date because there
are over three days old because the
schema the schema is changing constantly
and only about a month ago they
completely change how the learning plan
fight and worked but the main things to
concern is it does follow a lot of
c-sharp fundamentals so there's a
context and there's a way for you to
load data currently you have to load
this through CSV and if you want to load
in Jason you have to kind of
you have to load it in and then get the
I numeron ball from it and then you can
transform it so you can feature eyes and
normalize your inputs and then you have
trainers so trainers algorithms so all
these different algorithms that you can
apply and then it's a prediction engine
which is basically you've trained your
model and now you want to predict give
it a score so you send it some
sentiments and then you want to see how
it would work so let's let's give an
example so as I mentioned we built this
tool called should I send air and it's
using the azure sentiment analysis API
which is pretty good and but you're all
gonna try it now so potentially we're
gonna go over our free limit and it's
gonna stop working so thinking like
maybe we should just create our own
model so this is basically it at the
back sizing is that okay yeah so basic
I'm gonna keep it I've kept it all in
one page just to show you how little of
code this is so these two classes here
send some an issue in sentiment
predicament a predicament prediction and
then this is okayed so here we have our
context and here we have a text reader
so this is basically is just grabbing
values from a CSV and what the CSV is is
we have a training one and a test one
and it's just a big list of sentences
with a zero or one next to it defining
if it's profanity in this particular
data set though it is American so that
their tolerance of profanity is a lot
lower than ours and then here we have
what is known as a data view which is
basically just loading data into into an
object that we can do something to and
then here we have our trainer of which
there are many of them and many ways to
customize the properties but for the
purpose of this will keep it basic and
then we have a data processing pipeline
which is where we have to basically turn
our text and things and normalize our
bodies which in this case all we've got
is a sentence so all we have to do is
feature either text and what happens is
it turns that text into a vector of
floats using a process of pulling out
the and grams
I have no idea how that works and
neither do you the same way that you
probably don't need to unless you really
want to delve deep into this stuff but
we can trust Microsoft that it works
most of the time and then what we do is
we build up our training pipeline so
they have this concept of AC saying does
this pipeline fit the training data
don't know why they don't call it train
it would make a lot more sense but once
we've got our model we've now got a
trained model in this train model you
can you can export into a zip file and
then just stick it into your doc net
project and call it query it and if
you've got a million calls it won't cost
you a penny and that's your data but
before we do that we want to kind of
make sure it's kind of right so what we
do then is we also take in some test
data so as we can see here there's a
test file and this has just got a couple
by twenty test test bits of information
also saying if it's positive or negative
sentiment in this case it's a profanity
detector American profanity does hurt to
be clear and then here what we're gonna
do is we're basically gonna say of the
basically let's that's like what what's
the stats that we can get from this and
if it's cool then that's export is is it
so let me run this and then hopefully
make some more sense
just because I was
never do
what time
so basically this is gonna run it's
going to take a couple of seconds so
basically well that's done now is its
grab the the CSV files it's created the
model it's trained it and now it's
basically on this breakpoint to output
it and what we get is this metrics
property here can you see that okay on
the back I'll shout out the numbers
basically of an accuracy of about 72%
all right so let's for the purpose of
this let's just export that so we're
gonna export it out all as a zip file
but what we're gonna do is just have to
be export it we're gonna just we're
gonna test it so we're gonna load it
back in so here we're just loading them
as if that's been generated and we're
gonna send it something which is this
line here which is gonna say is the
sentence this is call is that offensive
and we're gonna look at this prediction
here and the things it now personally I
don't think that's offensive so we're
gonna think okay so maybe the date is
not right so let's run it again and
let's have a look at the metrics again
unless you can see that that's like 75
cents five lines of code so let's have a
look at the metrics so the matrix is
saying it's like 72 percent accurate but
if we delve in a bit more we can see
this negative recall and positive equal
and precision and what we've got here is
it only gets the negative ones right
like 44 percent of the time but it gets
the positive ones ready for 64 percent
at the time so this is this is typically
a problem because we just don't have a
lot of data
there's only 250 rows in there so let's
let's get some more data to try and
bolster this up on 40 I don't have a lot
of I don't have a voice you have a lot
of sentiment and data on swearing I'm
sure you could contribute but I do have
here's one I made earlier on sarcasm
so here we go so basically this is a
list of headlines actually before we
delve into that let me just show you
this so if you're looking at so if
you're looking for data so this is the
biggest problem of this stuff if you
work at a big enterprise and you have
access to a multitude of historical
information then you're in a good place
if you're looking to test something or
do something new like getting the data
and getting good data is the problem who
was seen quick-draw by Google right this
is awesome
so basically it will try and guess what
you're drawing as you draw it so draw a
Draper Jekyll icy square oh I know it's
Jail what you spend hours doing this I
see I or bread I see mouths oh I know
it's sleeping bag okay you get the idea
oh I know it's boomerang but what's so
cool about this it works on your phone
but you know you can wait like 20
minutes but what's cool about that is
you can get the data set of all the
pictures that everybody's submitted so
now you have like a whole massive image
library of data the same way that if
there's a thing called image net which
is watch a lot of the image I'll wear
them to use and you can just search for
a word and it will just give you access
to these images I knew I should have
showed that quick-draw thing at the end
and then if you're doing things on voice
Mozilla have a thing called common voice
which is a way to give you an open data
set of loads of different voices from
around the world for you to build kind
of diverse voice experiences and then
there's a service called as many of
these but there's one called goggle
which gives you data sets where I got
the sarcasm warmth from where you can
basically you can also run competitions
to get this information so let's just
drop back into our sample so we've got a
sarcasm data and again it's been split
into her I've just opened the 50ml JSON
file
so it's been split into two files our
testing one on a training one and then
if we go into here it's exactly the same
code the only difference is is we're
just pointing in pointing it to these
two different CSV files and in this case
the text column is first and the
sentiment of if it's sarcastic or not is
at the end whereas on the previous one
it was at the beginning so if we weren't
on this one so this one takes a bit
longer so this is loading in about
29,000 lines and we'll test the Gator
but they test against about 1,500 so it
takes a few more seconds so here we've
loaded in our metrics now this one is
getting accuracy of about 89% but more
importantly it's positive and negative
recall is of 91 and 89 91% and 88% so
it's a bit more trusting so if we now
look at good morning how are you
surprisingly only does not think that
has been a sarcastic only 21 percent
which is cool now not willing to just
try anything and disrupt the dream let's
go with man swings to work as it's
quicker
so this is going to come back and this
as as you can imagine I wouldn't pick
something there's another work this is
going to show to us but this one he
believes is 90% sarcastic so this is
cool
the thing is is this data you know this
is sarcastic data it works but in this
case it's American information so it's
not going to work for every different
version of what we're doing so what do
you you know so what you do so basically
needs to gather your data you really
need to hone in how you're going to get
this but let's go with something that's
a bit more yes or no so there's a great
example in the github repo around taxis
I've stripped and stripped it down into
this case so this is basically
predicting the taxi fare so if you think
you BIR deliver ooh any of these
applications that give you a your you
know your cab this is how much it will
cost it will cost between 20 and 50 and
15 pounds we can kind of we can do that
so how this will work training data
again a lot of these records which
basically just says the passenger count
how long the trip cost how long it took
and the distance so we load all this
information in and again the same as
before we load the data in comma
separated we read it in this time low
through probably previous trial and
error we've realized that the model only
really works between a certain price
like most of these taxi trips have been
be quite small and occasionally someone
forgets their car and just like a trip
to Vegas from New York or something so
we want to exclude them so once we've
loaded our training data and our test
data in you can then filter based on the
column so you can here you can just say
by this column I just want to filter out
anything that is above or below $1 and
above room $50 and then we're gonna
build on pipeline so here because we
have got quite a varied set of data of
the numerical values we just want to
normalize it so that we can kind of
bring the information in a bit closer
and once we've got it we're gonna we're
gonna train our model the same way as we
did before and then we're gonna evaluate
it and what this means is then we can
basically say someone wants to take a
trip with one passenger
forty that's roughly three kilometers
away and what it will do is it will spit
out the answer and a model for that
hold on
[Music]
okay
to develop a style
okay so so this actual Amtrak would cost
around fifteen dollars so let's have a
look so say fifteen point nine so
there's a kind of tolerance there of off
by a dollar but if you're kind of just
getting an estimate for the trip it's
between this and this like that's that's
that's good enough
but let's thing we've now created our
model so we've got this is if I like
what can we do with it and how easy is
it to add in so as I mentioned earlier
we had created this this little plugin
called should I send it for Chrome so
this is basically the code for that
exact plug-in so we we go and just kind
of validate some stuff and then we
basically call the azure API to get the
sentiment and then based on the the
result that comes back is it over 65%
we'll say it's positive if it's less
than forty five or six negative and if
it's in the middle we'll just call it
neutral and if you want to put in your
own plug-in your own model it's as
simple as just replacing that little bit
of snippet of code here which is where
we're just talking to the API
just replacing that with this which is
where we're just going to grab that zip
file we're just going to read it in and
then we're just going to create a
prediction engine and then we're just
going to pass the text to it and return
back the probability and get a positive
or negative response so it's all all
very straightforward
but we've got to think like what what
other things could we do what other
amazing not waste of time things could
we do
John ski this week my arch-nemesis so
John's on in spring one currently John
also spoke at the Google me up two days
ago which I couldn't go to because I was
speaking the other night and luckily I
thought this room would be empty due to
this so I felt like how how can I
channel my inner skeet so that you know
so that we could do some great stuff now
unfortunately the demo gods are against
me but John sweets so what we could do
as we could just grab John's tweets and
we could create a learning algorithm
around how John talks and then we could
grab how other people talk you can
actually use a stack overflow API so you
could grab all of his answers on Stack
Overflow which are a few and then you
could grab like how you speak or how
other people speak and then you could
optimize this algorithm and then actual
writing the emails or your answering on
Stack Overflow you could go is this how
John would do here and you could just
select that text and then it would give
you ask equal score
really life-changing stuff and basically
this but this is the thing so you can
you know if you think about this in the
respect of like we do a lot of
regression stuff so there's all this
clustering thing and there's a lot of
other things you can do with this but
the ability to predict and give a kind
of sentiment or understanding is the
thing we found like that's what
companies are really embracing other
women and be you could load also stuff
like you know I would like to sound more
Shakespearean in how I write the list
continues and as I mentioned with the
voice back thing that we've created so
we'd we'd used a lexer and then we'd use
Chris which is as yours speech speech
kind of API and then we were like we
kind of want to customize this billfold
because Chris is there as your tool and
doesn't have support for a UK British so
if you digitize a person's voice you do
get because you're kind of you're
building on top of their models and then
adding your sentences in so you kind of
get this American twang to what's being
said so then we were thinking right what
we need to kind of get a role model that
we like intends a flow unfortunately
because ml don't know at the moment only
supports the ability to predict ends up
with our models you can't train them but
apparently it would be me coming to
long-term so so that's how unfortunate
I'll show it to you because hopefully
this is what's going to get me like a
really nice house one day um but but
basically this model is a way for us to
basically create even more humanistic
voices using things like wave now and be
able to store this stuff in the client
and then privacy so this is probably the
biggest thing to bear in mind for two
reasons one who's heard of this thing
called gdpr so as a consumer gdpr is
awesome like I love it I love just going
to recruiter saying delete my
information now and but one thing that's
bad about it is AI models need data and
you don't really know what data is going
to work and how you're gonna get it so
if you're in a company you'll say
we want to start predicting the
occupancy level of our gym or of our
hotel or of our restaurant and I gotta
go cool but we can't give you the
information so you kind of have to have
a real solid business case for how this
is going to work you might even have to
start collecting this data yourself just
to prove the model but it's important
and it's important that we both have
their respect for kind of consumer
privacy but also if you're going to do
these types of things that you have this
ability to respect the the model and how
and how it needs this information it's
just a don't just run headfirst and can
I borrow this data I'm gonna stick into
the model because in theory that model
is based on that data and if you want to
try and explain in terms of conditions
how that person's data has been used in
the model but you don't explain how the
model works and then it's a difficult
thing so I just want to finish with one
last bit which is so these are all the
photos that were in this presentation
I'm going to go a bit down brown on you
now so I grabbed her 1,400 pictures off
SlideShare of the most viewed slides and
popularity and I ran it against the
pictures I thought I would want to add
into this presentation and based on the
audience and the age and roughly
demographics of the people I would
expect in the room these are the
pictures that came out as being the most
popular and basically what this means
and then a little bit tweaked based on
human emotion one of these pictures will
resonate with you so like with really
where we try and kind of make things
convenient with our clients
this will make this talk the most
convenient talk for you remembering
today however there is one bad thing
about it even this has a bias so if you
look back on here apart from the girl
you see any pictures of females so if we
go all the way back I added one it in so
as Amanda
we'll go there eventually
so I did I did this picture in and
because all the slides are up the ones I
viewed haven't got pictures of females
in as role models for development and
kind of driving this stuff forward and
so the data just said well why would it
suggest one so sometimes the data will
have a bias sometimes you have to go
against what the machine says to kind of
make the change I hope that was finished
up early I hope that was useful any
questions if there's snaps questions I
will not be able to answer them thank
you
[Applause]